inflation's at a 40-year high and lots
of people are wondering what the hell's
going on in bitcoin bitcoin's price has
come down 57 from its all-time high but
one of the beauties of the bitcoin
market is that we have on-chain metrics
we can literally go look right on a
blockchain and understand who's buying
who's selling who paid what for their
bitcoin and how long have they been
holding it one of the metrics that i
continue to pay attention to is this one
right here what it shows is how much of
bitcoin circulating supply has not moved
in at least one year and what you can
see is that blue line continues to tick
upwards it's sitting right now at an
all-time high 65.5
of all bitcoin in circulation has not
moved in at least a year even though the
price has gone up the price has gone
down inflation has gone up and there's
been all sorts of geopolitical risk in
the world
supply chains maybe get disrupted and
lots of investors are speculating in
markets but 65.5 of bitcoin has not
moved over the last 12 months those are
the long-term holders those are the
strong hands they bought bitcoin they
understand bitcoin and they realize that
is probably one of the most certain
things in an uncertain world if you
listen to someone like michael saylor i
think that looking at these metrics
continues to tell a story that's very
different than the public narrative
65.5 of all bitcoin not moving in a year
means not only is the finite asset of 21
million bitcoin actually more illiquid
than most people think because the 19
million bitcoin or so that are in
circulation
65.5 percent aren't moving that leaves
only about 35 or so available for people
to buy and sell new demand to soak up
and so of course there hasn't been any
sort of strong catalyst in the last
couple of months but if you have a
highly illiquid market and there is some
catalyst some change in demand in the
future it likely will lead to an
explosive move upwards in price now i
don't know when that happens i don't
know what the catalyst will be but this
is a very similar market dynamic to what
we saw going all the way back to q3 q4
of 2020.
at that point the market got to a very
high level of illiquidity and of course
we had people arguing that gbtc trade
inflation was on the horizon and as soon
as paul tudor jones and many other
people started to say that they were
buying bitcoin lots and lots of new
demand showed up you also had the
bitcoin having in may of 2020 all
drivers of that new demand and when that
occurred bitcoin went from about 10 000
all the way up to sixty four thousand
dollars in march of 2021. now i'm not
saying that we're gonna get the same
severity of a move but what i am saying
is that the market structure the
illiquidity that you can see and measure
based on these on-chain metrics it's a
repeat of what we've seen in the past if
there is a catalyst there is an increase
in demand it should lead to something
that we've seen before as well which is
a very rapid increase in price now the
us dollar price is the only thing that
can move you have a fixed supply asset
and you have an increase in demand in
order to accommodate everyone the price
goes up be interesting to watch this if
the illiquidity persists at some point
we'll get that catalyst and then it'll
be the fireworks that many of the
bitcoin community are waiting for